well we are a little bit more than uh
two months away now from the grand
opening of the resorts world
the actual date was revealed not only to
the public but also along the side of
the building it's going to open june
24th eight news now reporter joe moeller
is live now with the big announcement on
the strip's brand new mega resort joe
yeah we've watched the tower for resorts
world go up over the past year or so and
today the giant monitors outside of it
changed to announce the june 24th
opening date now guests can now book
reservations on the resorts website
i checked online for the first weekend
rooms start at around 370 dollars and go
up from there
you can also book reservations for the
new day club pool and nightclub
this will be the first resort to open
its doors in over 10 years on the strip
tourism and gaming experts say this will
change the northern part of the strip
i spoke to the president of resorts
world las vegas scott sabila
he says the opening is coming at a vital
time for the city
there has been anything like this in 10
years so we're extremely excited that
we're bringing a great property to las
vegas but we're also excited that
it could be perfect timing to help the
city rebound with a property like this
so so we're happy that we can be
part of that and we think it's gonna be
a great summer
sabila says majority of the work inside
is done and some finishing touches are
still
being done they're also working to
attract locals and they're working on
some marketing programs for that now
back out here live the resort is costing
more than four billion dollars to build
you're taking a look at the construction
that is continuing
uh the president there today also said
that the resort is on time to finish
june 24th and is
also on budget reporting live here near
the strip joe moeller 8 news now